in today's action we saw the number one  player in the United States Cara  Nakamura defeat the number to play in  the world levon aronian after aronian  blundered horribly with the move Queen  to be five yeah her as it's embarrassing  I can rarely make fun just like this I'm  really embarrassed in the other game  world number one Magnus Carlsen crushed  reigning US Champion gotta calm ski and  pleased with his victory had this to say  about playing a devastated Aronian in  tomorrow's round I'll try to to pound  something on that of course to continue  my momentum try and kick him ball is  down be sure to tune in tomorrow for  live rounds and coverage of the sink  filled cup at one p.m. Central 2 p.m.  eastern at st. Louis chess club com